c'est devenu le rituel des écoliers même
quoi depuis le 20 septembre avant de
rentrer dans la cantine ils récupèrent
leurs serviettes en tissu encore
quelques oublis mais la démarche est
déjà comprises j'ai divatte et c'était
bien pour l'écologie de la planète en
gâcherait -2 de papier pour parce que le
papier c'est avec les arbres et j'aime
la nature c'est bien comme ça on utilise
monde serviette et ça fait il ya moins
de pollution tous les lundis on met là
la serviette dans le casier et tous les
vendredis on la récupère en place un
changement d'habitudes qui permet
d'économiser 100 mille serviettes en
papier par an une volonté de la mairie
une serviette en papier mais trois mois
à se décomposer
ça fait partie d'une démarche plus
globale par rapport à la réduction des
déchets et notamment au niveau de la
restauration scolaire on a d'abord
commencé à réduire notre usage du
plastique de manière générale donc par
rapport à ça on travaille avec des
barquettes compostables par exemple
depuis maintenant deux trois ans la
municipalité a aussi distribué des
gouttes pour limiter les usages des
bouteilles en plastique lors des
pique-niqué au quotidien la ville
introduit aussi des produits issus du
commerce local dans les menus des écoles